this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today's guest is Tim Carney he is
a senior columnist at the Washington
examiner and a senior fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute he is also
the father of six children thank you so
much for joining us Tim hey thanks for
having me so you recently wrote uh a
book called family unfriendly I don't
even know if it's been released yet I'm
pretty sure the publication date uh is a
few months from now so hopefully viewers
will check it out once it is released
but you know you basically lay out a
very interesting case for how American
culture and businesses can really become
a lot more approachable for families um
lay out the the Doom day scenario for us
uh if there's this fertility bust that
continues uh for many decades to
come yes so since uh 2008 at least when
the Great Recession happened the the
birth rate in the United States just
plummeted which was expected that's what
happens in for the short period in
economic downturns but it never
recovered it's been falling since then
and the Millennials who were much more
numerous in my generation Gen X when
they came on the scene people expected
massive baby boom that hasn't happened
so this has been going on for 15 years
there are now fewer children in America
today than there were at the last census
there are more people in their 60s in
America than there are in their zeros
that is under 10 and so if this
continues what we're going to see is the
uh Workforce is uh naturally going to
shrink and we could talk about social
security or that sort of thing I think
that's all secondary to the fact that
there will be fewer people doing work
that's the economics of it I could go on
and and family and friendly I do for a
few chapters about sort of the social
ramifications I think that we are we're
sadder we're less optimistic when there
are fewer children around and then it
spirals into the the culture that you've
already referred to when we have fewer
children we stop kind of building
culture to support families parents and
children and thus we lead to even fewer
and fewer children South Korea is seeing
exactly that and they've fallen down
below one child per uh per woman of
childbearing age we're down at about 1.6
1.7 Europe is down at about 1.5 and so
and the rest of the world is is falling
as well so in the future if we don't
start having more kids we'll have a
shrinking population an aging population
not enough people to do work but more
important I think we'll have a sort of a
sadder less trusting less loving society
when people don't have kids around them
but how bad will this well how bad will
this actually be like what is will this
be something that is like noticeable 10
20 years from now or will it sort of be
the US continuing on the trajectory set
by Europe where you walk around Europe
and it's not as if there's you know it's
immediately apparent that it's a
completely decaying Society right like
how how bad is it actually forecasted to
be in the United
States well so again uh South Korea is
the example where they are down below
one child the replacement level is
2.1 and there again you do see a a real
increase of sadness a real decrease of
even the idea of getting married there's
fewer and the idea of having children
and so become self-reinforcing so that's
why I don't think it's a slow steady
decline it's a kind of thing that uh
that spirals out of control that the the
fewer children the more uh the more
family unfriendly our our culture gets
and just to look at the economics the
working age population which the federal
figures on this count starting at age 15
that's already flatlined so then the
question is so then the the fact is that
in a few years that will start declining
and will decline every year for the
foreseeable future that's happened in
Japan we have fewer people doing work
and more people in retirement that's
going to be a lot of problem I don't
care how big your retirement savings are
if there's not somebody you can hire to
fix the leaky pipe in your apartment
it's it's no good to you and that will
start happening in our lifetime in for
me when I'm retired for you guys when
you're retired that will be the reality
that there'll be fewer and fewer workers
and again I don't think we can overstate
the cultural impact of places where all
the schools are going out of business
where all the playgrounds are getting
overgrown where then in turn the rest of
the culture stops even thinking about
children let me pull up a little bit of
some some data that you cited here just
because it helps people to see I think
sometimes what you're talking about
here's the US total fertility rate uh
derived from World Bank data uh you see
a steep uh decline from
1960 to 1980 and then a slower decline
from 1980 to present uh and then we've
got you mentioned the percentage or the
total number of children un know people
under the age of 18 in the US flatlining
there and then this shows the total
number of children as a percentage
relative to the total number of seniors
aged 65 and over and you see those lines
starting to converge and project uh
projected to flip in the not too distant
future um and then this is the world
fertility rate uh at 2.4 according to to
the United Nations and projected to
continue downwards so I guess my
question taking all that into account
is like how is a shrinking
population necessarily a terrible thing
I mean if if we have lifespans
increasing more perhaps more importantly
Health spans increasing and then
technology continuing to
create more goods and
services presumably bringing things down
and filling some of those gaps where the
you know if the workforce is shrinking
you know C can automation come in and
play a role and like how much how much
different I guess would the world look
whether we have 10 billion in the in the
year 20 2100 or six billion um is that a
is it a terrible change in quality of
life for the average American or the
average global
citizen one way to think about it is
this when you retire and so let's look
over 150 year span even though we
probably don't have to go back that far
when you retire when you're not able to
really make a lot of money later on or
when you're just tired and you want to
kind of rest because you're 70 75 years
old will you have your own children
taking care of you which is a very
traditional model kind of on its way out
maybe with six kids I'll be able to have
that who knows will you have sort of a
assisted living facility where there's
staff there and and they're taking care
of you and they're you know cooking
dinner and and check and there's nurses
to check on you if you're sick or will
you have a little robot with AI zooming
up to take care of you now maybe that
robot will have fewer you know uh
medical mistakes and and less
malpractice than human doctors and and
nurses I don't buy into that techno
Utopia future and I don't think most
people do I think that when we have
fewer people who are young enough to do
the work it will necessarily have
negative cultural effects it will
decrease trust a lot of the studies I
point out in the book show how just
being around children makes people more
generous with their time this is
non-parents even being around children
makes people more generous with their
time dealing face Toof face with humans
who we know
uh does more to build social trust does
more to improve people's moods than
dealing with uh faceless bureaucracies
with you know automated processes and
that kind of thing so if if you really
just prefer dealing with artificial
intelligence and robots and computers to
dealing with people then maybe the baby
bust is a is good news but uh no in
general I think for most people it will
it will absolutely be bad news and again
when you look at the the uh when you
look at the cultures where this is
happening nobody would tell you that
Japan and South Korea which are far
ahead on the baby bus represent happier
places than say uh the the countries you
know United States or northern Europe
where we're at least closer to
replacement level or Israel which I talk
a lot about in the book which has a
birth rate over over three babies per
woman of childbearing age the the the a
shrinking society and an aging Society
think inevitably is a sadder society and
I I lay out lots of arguments for that
in in the book as well as a techno
utopian Catholic I just want to make it
very clear that I want to have as many
children as possible and then in my old
age I want them to be AI enhanced uh to
be able to help with medical diagnosis
but I I do still want like my kids to be
taken care of me right like surely
there's a middle ground for those techno
utopian Catholics out there right yeah
and I'm I'm a uh yeah and you know I'm
I'm a father of three uh so you know I I
I love being around kids um Liz has a a
baby and I'm uh hopefully more on the
way uh in not too distant future uh
we're we're both amateurs uh in relation
to your your brood of six um but you
know at the bot the bottom the bottom
line for me is I I'm as a Libertarian I
don't really care how many children any
individual chooses to have um what I do
care about is our people unable to have
the number of children that they want to
have and so one of the stats that you
cite uh regularly in your book um that
was concerning to me was this gap
between the number of children that
people say they want to have and the
number they end up having um this is
just one example of the the polling on
this question gallet polling over the
years showing 48% of people want two
children
uh this is Americans uh 25% say three
133% say four or more uh so you know a
large majority want at least two kids I
think you put the number somewhere
between two and three is the average
like 2.4 2.5 something like
that the mean comes out to be 2.7 but on
that on that chart one of the most
important things is it's 5% that say
they want one or none that's that's
below what I call the the brown cow line
of polling some of you guys might
remember a poll that came out about 10
years ago that for some reason asked
people where does chocolate milk come
from and one of the answers was it comes
from cows like regular milk but those
are brown cows and that's why it's
chocolate that was 7% 7% is a negligible
number in any poll you had 5% of
African-Americans at one point say that
the uh the Emancipation Proclamation was
a mistake so these are people who like
misheard the question or trolling the
pster and that's the level of people who
say they want zero or one we and I think
they are over represented I think all of
those 5% of the people who who meant to
answer the question that way I think
they're all columnists at the Washington
Post right now because you would assume
that there's a massive childree by
choice or I just want to have one kid by
reading the main media but that's the
most shocking thing about that yet
people are ending up increasingly with
zero or one children um and so and I
think it's it's sad that the number of
people who say they want less than four
is falling but again we can bracket that
question uh what people want what people
choose as commentators we we try to
nudge people one way or another but from
a perspective of cultural or policy
failures if people want two and three
kids yet they're getting between one and
two and a record number are getting zero
then that shows us that something is
wrong now I'm based in Washington and
yeah sorry go on no I I just want to
know like how much can we infer from
that uh or you know what can we infer
from that in terms of changing
expectations like once you have one kid
or two kids and you start to realize
okay maybe this was more timec consuming
than I expected and I'm gonna like dial
back my expectations a little bit or my
desires change uh once I started having
kids um you know how how much do we know
about that changing
psychology the most of what I've seen uh
that the biggest thing that has changed
is the optimism that and the desire to
have multiple kids and keep working
full-time in your current job outside of
the home
that's where after baby number one the
uh the expectations get dialed down and
some people will say okay you know what
I can only have one kid because I can't
afford two dayc carees or something but
in fact a larger portion say you know
what I just don't value work as much as
I did before I had the first kid so
there's definitely a recalibration of
expectations but it's mostly how much
can you straddle a full-time job and
being a parent and uh another thing to
so again for me this reflects that
there's something wrong if people want
this thing and then decide that it's Out
Of Reach so the way I I phrase it is
what is the ideal family size well we
often fall short of our ideals so then
we have intentions that are less than
our ideals on anything right I have an
ideal house I'm house shopping I'm not
GNA get that what what do I expect or
intend that's always going to fall short
of your ideals but then what people
Millennials especially are attaining is
far less than even what they intend or
expect so their intentions are are a lot
lower than their ideals and what they
get is a lot less than their intentions
or expectations to me that reflect a
real cultural problem well so how much
can this be chalked up I mean this is a
huge debate within the sort of
pronatalist circles and I think
Libertarians tend to have a lot of push
back on this how much can this be
chalked up to women choosing of their
own valtion based off of you know their
own analysis of tradeoffs to have
children later uh what do you make of
that and how do you factor that into the
equation because the thing that I
definitely don't want to get into is a
situation where a bunch of pundits are
you know shaming women for choices that
they made that may be good choices where
they had full information or maybe kind
of sad choices where they wish they'
done something different but regardless
there's a little bit of this like well
this is the cultural shift that we see
as women enter the workforce and have
more opportunities available to them in
greater numbers than ever
before well so certainly when people say
that having kids is less affordable um
the fact is that's mostly false except
for in two ways in the last four years
or five years housing prices have gone
crazy but the baby bus is 15 years old
so the housing affordability question um
can't really explain what's been
happening for the last 15 years
the other way in which it's become the
real way in which it's become less
affordable every year for the last 30
years to have children is that the
opportunity cost has gone up
specifically because women are more
educated they're more educated than men
in America today and they have much more
professional opportunity than they did
in the past and so that is a real
tradeoff and life is full of trade-offs
we can't get rid of tradeoffs but my
argument is that there are things that a
culture can do some through policy some
through uh other cultural forces and you
mentioned employers and I would say
communities and all sorts of things
religious communities uh local libraries
Etc extended families our individual
choices there are things we can do to
make it easier to reduce the severity of
the tradeoffs to reduce the opportunity
cost of having kids whether it's uh Visa
a career or VISA just having a social
life and that's the job of culture is to
make it easier for people to attain
their ideals and to lessen the cost of
people pursuing real worthwhile Noble
ideals you know there was this video
that was circulating the internet a few
weeks ago about the uh the dink
Community the double income no kids uh
there was a tick Tock Trend where people
are describing what is life as a dink
and why uh why am I choosing not to have
kids why am I choosing this child-free
life I thought that we could play uh
roll that clip of this one that went
viral uh because it's a good jumping off
point to talk a little bit more about
these tradeoffs and these Choice why
people are making these choices and how
much these choices are actually grounded
in the e iic reality so best could you
run the dinks clip for us we go to
Trader Joe's and workout classes on the
weekends we're dinks we get into snobby
Hobbies like skiing and golfing we're
dinks we can go to Florida on a whim
we're dinks we're already planning our
european vacation next year dinks we get
a full 8 hours of sleep and sometimes
more we're dinks we get desserts and
appetizers at restaurants we're dinks we
can play with other kids and give them
back we're dinks we still do it three
times a week we're dinks we spend our
discretionary income on $8 latte we're
dinks we max out our 401ks Roth ir and
hsas we're dinks we don't use our kids
or dog as an excuse to leave a party we
just
leave so I I mean my uh reaction to this
initially was like uh first of all it it
is funny and like you know it's okay to
be a dink and and Dink life is fun but I
felt that they were they were kind of
overstating some of the material
sacrifices but what what are your
thoughts on the dink video
Tim well first thing I I would think is
so I'm in a different stage of life than
you guys my oldest is a High School
junior my youngest is seven years old
and my wife my our problem is that our
our social life is too crowded because
through our kids uh friends and and we
have tons of parties and we're again
we're renting now and so we don't you
know host throw parties as much and one
of our kids I overheard somebody said oh
do your parents entertain a lot and one
of my kids said no my my parents are
entertained a lot because we're going to
other people's houses for parties and so
they're a they're comparing themselves
to people um you know with babies and
and very young children and not to
people with with grown children who you
know occasionally are able to get up and
leave um and on the other
hand the idea that maxing out your HSA
is like really something to celebrate
and talk about while on your vacation
and in Florida that struck me as sort of
a very sad note right there and this is
one of the things that I encountered as
I went around and I talked to people I a
big part of my job has always been what
I call Bar reporting or coffee shop
reporting just talking to strangers and
the great thing about writing a book on
parenting is that everybody has
something to say either they are parents
or they want to be or they've chosen not
to be and one of the the things was the
the sadness the the sort of banality of
the explanations behind why I'm not
going to become a parent a lot of times
it was one woman just said I'd love to
have kids I love spending time with kids
I'd love to have my own but it would it
would weaken my career a little bit and
then if my husband divorced me I I'd be
in a disadvantageous place so basically
it was like unemployment insurance it
was this insurance policy basically why
she was not making this choice and so
just to see some of those things it's
it's uh I mean we've all had bad reasons
for doing things and some of those are
are are pretty sad $8 loates um is a
pretty sad reason to not have kids yeah
and to your earlier point you know some
of there I feel like there's there are a
lot of economic myths out there um I
mean housing is one thing that's a
that's a serious impediment I think to a
lot of people having kids and we can
talk about housing a little bit later
but as you note in your book Millennials
have as much wealth as prior generations
and as you go up the wealth ladder to a
point you start having less kids so it's
not so clear that it's just about
economics um and um you know could it be
that some of that mythology just needs
to be punctured the idea that we're like
more strapped than ever and kids are
going to bankrupt
you no absolutely and um J HP doll is
the is this the numbers guy who's who
constantly does this he just does an
inflation adjusted uh wealth and income
comparing Boomers to Gen X I'm always
grateful that he remembers that we exist
because most commentators don't but
Boomers to Gen X to Millennials at a
given age and shows that the the wealth
is basically equal across those three
and um affordability of certain of goods
at a family would buy how does that
compare to you know hours of work and he
shows that that is largely stable across
the the last few decades and so the the
affordability thing I keep coming back
to culture I think part of it and uh
Angela rashidi who's my colleague at Ai
and Melissa Carney who's at uh Brookings
institution and and University of
Maryland they keep pointing out that
part of the reason that it feels so much
more unaffordable to raise kids and to
some extent is can be less affordable
depending on your life is that fewer
people have a culture that surrounds
them that helps them raise their kids
largely I'm talking about extended
family when my kids were little my
wife's little sister's babysat them now
that my wife's little sisters have
babies it's my oldest that same one who
they were babysitting she's babysitting
her cousins and that's a sort of culture
that's very Pro family that's very
supportive in Israel it's just very
explicit because people are expected to
have kids people are expected to help
other people take care of kids there's
not a mindset of oh your kids were your
choice like buying a boat so it's your
problem and I'm not really I'm not
talking about welfare state policies or
that sort of thing let talking about
cultural expectations you should help
people raise their kids you should have
a community that's Pro family that
expects people to show up at whatever
you're showing up with kids in tow and
that if if you live in a culture
subculture that's not familyfriendly you
think I have to pay for everything and
then life does start to become less
affordable yeah I have been thinking
about these themes so much because I
wrote a piece for Barry Weiss's
publication the Free Press um about
being a quote unquote young mom which is
a little bit of a an absurd thing
because I had my child at 26 right
that's not particularly Young by global
standards that's not even particularly
Young by American Standards uh it's the
medi the med median age at first child
in the United States for women is 26.3
so like right fully you know very much
the norm however in my millu of
journalists who live in New York City
upper middle class women college
educated went to like a pretty good
school that whole like subset of
American society this is something where
you know having a kid at 25 or 26 is
very unheard of and there's this
cultural expectation that you'll push it
off into later so the thing that's been
so interesting for me is like you know I
was in this like Park Slope moms group
and it was fascinating to me the things
that the 40-year-old moms because many
of them were legitimately you know 15
years older than me the things that they
think you need to have in place before
having a child and even the physical
Goods that they think you need it feels
as though we almost have concocted a
sort of absurd sense of how much having
a kid actually costs and surely if you
buy absolutely everything new and expect
to be shelling out $200,000 for your kid
to go to to uh you know us an excellent
Elite college and you're expecting to
pay for daycare for every single year um
you know so that you can maintain your
job sure having a kid is awfully
expensive but there are an awful lot of
ways to minimize these things and to
come up with more creative arrangements
to get around all of that um to me it
seems like there's like if we look at
things one way and if we assume that you
know X Y andz things must be in place
before starting a family of course it
seems unattainable to an entire
generation of of women but if we rethink
what things are necessary precursors it
really
changes absolutely and so I ran uh focus
groups and actually it was the men in my
focus groups who are more likely to say
look the reason I'm not ready and won't
be ready anytime soon to have kids is
because I don't want to just give them
the bare minimum I want to give them the
best of everything I can promise you
guys I do not we do not give our kids
the best of everything we we found a
used piano and it's still Out Of Tune
and they still love playing on it okay
they we send them once we made the
mistake of of travel baseball that's a
whole discussion in the book but
basically we send them to the local
wreck leagues and and all of that and
the you know they do the basic violin
lessons at school none of them has
gotten good at violin trumpet trombone
one son is good at guitar because he's
interested in girls now but we haven't
given them lessons or or the best of
everything and that idea that you do
have to give the kids the best of
everything that's again not just a cause
but a consequence of smaller families
this idea that I cite in the book of um
well it's good that we're choosing
quality parenting over quantity I argue
it's not good because it it makes people
think you have to give your kids these
really expensive enrichment Etc the best
of everything and then you have fewer
kids and then because you have fewer
kids you invest more in each that's not
necessarily even good for the kids or
the parents if everybody is constantly
anxious that playing the piano goes from
something fun to do around Christmas
with Christmas carols to being basically
a job that's going to get you your
scholarship into college nobody's
happier or the high quote quality
parenting isn't high quality it's just
more expensive and more anxiety
inducing I love that part of the book
because um you're you touch on so many
themes that uh it's basically just like
parents can you chill out a little bit
um this is like very present in the work
of Lenor sceni with Freer range
parenting um or Brian kaplan's uh you
know selfish reasons to have more kids
the themes that unite all three of these
kind of schools of thought uh is like
you don't need to be putting them uh all
your kids on this uh pre-formed track to
get to some magical destination you can
let things play out a little more
spontaneously a little bit the challenge
then is like if we're in this culture
that that does uh kind of incentivize
getting on that track what do you think
are the best ways to escape that is it
just a kind of bottomup uh
countercultural
movement yeah I'm being countercultural
and this is one of the things that I've
done I've started multiple baseball
teams I the book uh family unfriendly
starts with the t-ball program I
discovered and then copied which which
is all based around being actually
familyfriendly the point of my t-ball
program was to bring all your kids and
ignore them including the one playing
t-ball while we serve burgers to your
family the baseball teams I started I
told the parents we're not going to
practice we're just gonna go out and
play the game we didn't even have the
take sign in other words we told our
kids if you can hit the ball hit the
ball because baseball's more fun that
way and our job is not to improve your
stats and win as many games but to have
fun playing baseball and maybe you'll
get get better at it and try out for the
Varsity squad one day but uh but yeah
being countercultural and you find that
people gravitate towards that they say
oh I'm allowed to not care so much about
it and to to so it was with my my second
half of my children that I started being
very loud and explicit and not just
trying to say you know what I want this
but to just loudly say hey I'm starting
a baseball team that's not going to
practice we're just going to play in the
games who wants in and boom
uh people come so there there's that
demand for it but people feel bad
because they nobody wants to choose
lower quality uh parenting but being
countercultural really is uh absolutely
necessary and new parents can be can be
reluctant to do that yeah and it does
seem like that is a part of your your
case for you know having six kids is you
cannot helicopter parent six of them the
helicopter is not fast enough to get to
all of them or you know you can't tiger
mom
um you know another part of your kind of
bar bar stool or shoe leather reporting
is you were talking to a lot of people
uh who were referencing the movie
Idiocracy the Mike Judge film uh which
has a very famous introduction uh and
I've also pulled that clip which I want
to roll and talk about a little bit uh
best could you play the idiocracy
clip Evolution does not necessarily
reward an intelligence with no natural
predators to thin the herd it began to
Simply reward those who reproduced the
most and left the intelligent to become
an endangered
species having kids is such an important
decision we're just waiting for the
right time it's not something you want
to rush into obviously no
way oh I'm pregnant again I
got too many damn kids thought you was
on the pill or some hell no oh must
have been thinking of Britney Britney
no there's no way we could have a child
now m- not with the market the way it is
no God no that just wouldn't make any
sense come on over here he don't
care about you yeah but un must be
something he likes over here mean
nothing to me
baby oh it wasn't me it wasn't
me well we finally decided to have
children and I'm not pointing fingers
but it's not going well
no and this is helping I'm just saying
that before I have initro maybe you
should be willing to it's always me
right well it's not my sperm
count so implications are obvious having
a lot of kids is for stupid people um
why do you think Endeavor right like
that's
the exactly what why do you think that
it has such cultural resonance what does
that say about attitudes towards kids
and
family U and I I love it because I first
heard about that uh movie The First Time
anyone ever asked me have you watched
idiocracy I was at a a reason happy hour
and said to one of my friends there that
I was expecting my second in 2008 and
she said oh have you seen ocracy and I
think she meant it in a a friendly uh
joking way but uh then when she
explained the plot I wasn't sure how to
take it um and yeah and this is
something I encountered in a a
playground in New Milford Connecticut
which I highlight as a a shrinking town
the playground was outside of elementary
school that's closed down and was
currently hosting senior yoga instead as
sort of the the the future and I think
again the idea that it's smart and both
sides get mocked in this movie right
like the the yuy couple with the 140 IQs
are not coming out as as the you know
The Prudent the the people to look up to
but right really the idea that raising
kids is this because it's become such a
choice because it's not just kind of
something you do now there are
subcultures where finish school get a
job get married have kids is just kind
of what you're expected to do and well
if you're going to deviate from that
you're making a different Choice that's
fine but now it's not even that it's not
expected it's it's like choosing what
color sweater you're going to put on in
the morning it's it's an explicit Choice
it's a a lifestyle choice because of
that a it the it leads to a culture that
says it's your problem if you have kids
but B it makes you feel and I quote
Stephanie Murray who's a great parenting
writer on this it it once it becomes a
choice then you have to do it all
exactly right it's like you I would tell
my kid don't go to college if you're not
going to try to get good grades and that
kind of thing and this is what people
say if you're not going to absolutely do
it right make sure you have everything
in order make sure you have the house in
the right school district and you have
the savings to send them to college and
you have lined up the piano teacher Etc
then don't do it and so that's again the
way in which I think it's a
self-reinforcing thing as people have
fewer children their perception of the
amount of inputs you need to do into
child rearing goes up which then makes
parenting seem more daunting which
causes people to put it off and
sometimes you put it off too long and
it's no longer in the cards for you to
me the opposite vision of this is is um
The Sound of Music right like there's a
little bit of horseshoe Theory at play
where it's like okay the poor and low
class family and idiocracy okay they
have a ton of kids but then there's also
we see this actually um in a lot of the
data surrounding this sometimes it's the
ultra wealthy families like you know
Christopher Palmer's family and Sound of
Music who end up having a whole bunch of
kids and then they essentially live the
libertarian dream right like they have a
governance they do micr schooling like
it's it's an awesome sort of like means
of you know you can really scale up the
family but so do we need cultural
messages like that where we also show
this being like a very high class thing
or do we need cultural messages where
it's just seen as like Ultra attainable
to you what's the what's the IDE
Universal manners yeah we need Maria to
come and raise all of the children for
all of the families I don't think
perfectly behaved kid the image of
perfectly behaved kids is the the right
one um to give a an example I'm try to
get my kids to hold especially my sons
to hold open doors for people because
that's really easy to teach them and
it's really easy to just say one word as
you walk by them door and then they'll
hold the door open and that makes other
people happy and it's really my kids
can't sing in unison again I have a son
who can play the guitar and that's the
extent of the music and I actually go
they don't wear little outfits made out
of curtains you don't have anybody
making them outfits out of drapes or
anything what's the point of having
I criticize the mom fluenc in my book
The you know the Instagram moms who
everything is perfect and specifically
the ones who they all live in farmhouses
is a bizarre thing that I can't
understand and the reason it's I you I
can understand because it's supposed to
look oh well we are going a simple route
I mean that Farmhouse they made with the
first five million they made off of
their influencer cash um they often
started with cash and the simple rout
like you notice a denim is all like made
to point perfectly towards the Hues of
the ballerina mother's blue eyes right
like it's none of it is simple it's all
extremely curated none of that helps
people have kids because that's what
causes people say oh I have to have my
life that much in order to raise kids to
have kids who are basically Happy who
you know and they eat nuggets and french
fries for dinner at least once a week
that's the kind of attainable image of
the parent I actually praise in family
unfriendly I praise the lawn that's
scattered with like footballs and
tricycles and there's some dead grass
from where the you know the home plate
was left or the skateboard was left
upside down to be a little bit messy and
happy and that sort of thing and not not
perfect kids not ivy league kids so I
you know have lower Ambitions for your
kids is one of the me I have in the
first two chapters for the book maybe
it's not idiocracy or Sound of Music
maybe it's like Cheaper by the Dozen
remember like that movie I guess there
was the original one and then the Steve
Martin remake right even Cheaper by the
Dozen um because he's like militaristic
that did set for me a tone and I admit
in the book I say when I'm a bad dad
when I lose my temper it's because I
want to think of myself as militaristic
like if I Whistle my dogs come a certain
whistle and Cheaper by the Dozen he has
a certain whistle where his 12 kids come
and again there's a couple things I'm
I'm good at which is my kids open the
door and they behave well in Mass but
after that I I try to be you know
relatively Laz fair with uh with the
kids don't always succeed at that but
yeah that that that that model that the
things you think you need to do for your
kids you don't they might look like a
mess sometimes your house will look like
a mess sometimes your kids won't get
into to Harvard but that those things
are all fine that's the main message
that I think needs to get conveyed to
people now does that sound to you like
I'm saying you should live you know be a
dude having babies with all his
neighbors in the trailer park well if
they those sound the same to you I'm
sorry I don't have much to say but I
think you can see sort of a stable
couple with a a moderate income and just
trying to raise happy kids that that
definitely is doable even in this world
you do do have to change your
expectations so taking us to a Terrain
where maybe Zach will start to to fight
us Tim I did want to ask you you write
in the book about how our meritocratic
secular society has forgotten that we
have innate
value do you think that sense of innate
value can ever truly exist in a secular
society well I think that in I think
that ultimately it is our
secularization that makes us less
believe in innate value that makes us
think our kids have value if they
accomplish something good um and that
you know most reminded of Donald Trump's
horrible explanation for how he went
from being pro-choice to pro-life was he
knew this single woman who was pregnant
he thought she should have an abortion
18 years later she he meets the kid and
the kid was really successful in life so
he changed his mind that to me is like
the worst possible explanation for
welcoming life is this kid might get
into Harvard so don't abort him but I do
think that that reflects our secular
view of children that children are good
if they are successful in these
measurable ways and I do think that that
is a that
materialism uh is a fruit of a secular
society where we stop seeing people as I
mean I'm I'm a Catholic I think we are
made in the image of God I believe that
every human being
has basically infinite value but I don't
think that's an exclusively religious
argument I think it's inevitable that a
secularizing society will hold on to
that value less dearly but I also do
think that a secular society can see
okay wait a second if we do hold that
human life really is valuable in itself
that will ultimately all be happier in
other words I do think you can make an
almost almost make a utilitarian
argument for that idea that uh humans
have value but the fact is that the more
secular any society has gotten in recent
history there's been sadness that's gone
together with it and I think if we look
around today I think uh with Gen Z
especially you see a guilt and a dark
forboding fear of the future which is
supposedly what the fire and brimstone
preachers were were driving home but now
it's actually what the fire and
brimstone op ads about climate change or
driving home so I think it's hard to
really see human life as fundamentally
good in our current secular
society yeah I mean I I don't really
disagree too much of that I I think the
foundation of liberalism is really the
the Val the value of the individual um
you know it everyone is treated equally
under the law because everyone has an
equal amount of dignity that needs to be
respected um and you know in the book
it's interesting because you use Israel
which you've mentioned a couple times
and Utah as examples of unusually
fertile cultures and obviously a lot of
Jewish people in Israel a lot of Mormons
in Utah so religion plays a role but it
seemed like something emanates out and
it's not just the religious people
living in those areas who are unusually
fertile um what lessons do you draw from
places like Israel and Utah yeah so one
of the things I always say and I said
this in my previous book alienated
America is that the effect of religion
on cultures doesn't come from the
sermons as much as it comes from the
culture it doesn't come from the
catechism as much as it comes from the
culture that what happens is religious
institutions and religious-based
institutions of Civil Society build a
family friendly culture so I jokingly
say pregnancy is contagious because uh a
demographer in Utah told me that the
Catholics in America that have the most
babies are the Catholics who live in
Utah in other words living near Mormons
makes you get pregnant and so that it's
obviously not a virus that spreads in
the air but it is a culture that gets
built up by people who hold family very
dear they then build up a culture that
makes it easier you could if you want to
put in purely economic terms makes it
more affordable to have kids I put in
ecological terms they create fit
habitats for raising family so the most
important data point I got from Israel
was secular Jews which in the census
they are counted as their own categories
these are people who identify as Jews
but you know they'll eat bacon
cheeseburgers and shrimp and you know
the only they they might celebrate
Passover but they're not keeping the
Sabbath secular Jews in Israel average
2.0 children that's far more fertile
than any country in Europe and then the
United States so that is the religious
Jews have a lot more than that but the
culture that's built around the religion
the I I make an image of a garden it's a
garden that is uh creates an environment
an ecosystem that's pro- family and so I
even ran into this guy who was
complaining in Israel he was complaining
oh yeah the religious over in Jerusalem
they have too many kids y y and while he
was complaining about this he was
kicking a soccer ball with his
four-year-old son and then at one point
his wife came over and handed over his
two-year-old daughter to him and so I
was like the anti-id people in Tel Aviv
have two kids and they were young enough
they might have three or four I I would
take that over here what exactly like
break this down for us more you know I I
I don't want to be relegated to a fate
of sitting in you know Utah Chuck e-
cheeses for the rest of my life but I
assume it's more like you know kutum
like communal child rearing type stuff
than you know higher in prevalence of
Chuck-E-Cheeses like what is it exactly
about these cultures that makes it like
would Zach's family move to Utah and
immediately be just
thriving well so yeah in Israel one of
the lines that somebody told me was the
bus drivers in Israel have a real
affection for little children so just
imagine that where you send your
8-year-old to the bus stop not worrying
that the bus is going to pull away or
that the guy's going to bark at your kid
or anything like you just say the bus
driver is gonna stop and help the kid on
and and you know make sure somebody
gives him a seat there's another uh one
of the dads who was uh he's a he was
Orthodox he has two young kids or maybe
three he hopes to have a lot of kids and
he said well a six-year-old can walk to
school School six-year-old knows he
can't cross the street on his own and so
any adult who walks up to a crosswalk
knows there might be some stranger kid
there who you're going to wait and then
take them across the street the
expectations a restaurant it's normal to
have kids there if you need help with
your children somebody will help you out
all there is not the mindset your
children are your own problem there was
recently a Reddit um am I the
thread where this woman was like well my
my sister needed wanted to take a shower
and wanted me to watch the kids and I
said I have no obligation that was your
decision to have the kids I'm not even
going to watch your kids I mean a your
kid probably can be left alone while you
take a shower but B no you should help
your sister Ron Johnson the Republican
senator and opposing the child tax
credit said I've never thought that it
was anybody's it was society's
responsibility to help people raise
their kids you could set aside the
policy debate and say no actually I do
think in these in these subcultures and
the these cultures like Israel and Utah
it's there's just a ton of little
supports and expectation people are
going to have kids and we should all
help them out and support that in their
undertaking I wonder whether um thinking
about like the New York City restaurant
scene um whether there's also like
incentives for places to be more
family-friendly I think about you know
I've gotten icer treatment while
bringing my son um to certain
restaurants before but I'm thinking of
two places balazar in Manhattan which is
always extreme you know I think they
kind of let us jump in line a little bit
in terms of waiting for a table um
versus other people there's a little bit
of like accommodating families noticing
the children are hungry and then a place
called Bonnies in Williamsburg and I've
noticed that like there are certain
restaurants you know highend that I'll
go into in New York where I'm it stands
out because they're so accommodating
toward families and I do Wonder like to
what degree do they have a natural
incentive to do this because it's
something that at least like I noticed
this as a parent and it makes me
frequent these restaurants far more than
I would otherwise
it would be incred entire culture of
that where I never go into any New York
City restaurant and feel a sense that my
son is
unwelcome as as a parent of six I
actually my wife and I do occasionally
really relish a a childfree environment
but that's again that's uh if we we went
on our 15th anniversary to like an
Adults Only Resort and by the end of it
we were like four days is a maximum we
miss missed our kids I don't think we
missed our kids for the first three days
so if you're going to have a restaurant
that's basically going to be childfree I
there there's definitely a place for
that in society but that your normal
restaurant there was this great place
called hamburger hamlet in Maryland that
looks like a fancy restaurant but if you
show up with kids again you use the word
they accommodate you which is not
strictly treating everybody equal
they're actually giving a a special uh a
preference for the families with kids
because because the families with kids
need it because sitting at a table when
you're a little kid at a at a restaurant
is a hard thing to do because you don't
naturally sit still so that sort of idea
that culture accommodates families is uh
is important and the more that it
happens the more that it happens and
again it doesn't preclude having a a
small set of uh childfree places it does
mean that the norm is you expect to kids
to be brought to that place if you go to
a conference and speak in a conference
in the United States nobody has their
kids there unless it's like a super
Catholic or super Mormon conference and
in Israel though that the speaker who
has a PHD will be up there and his kids
will be running around in the in the
front of the audience that I I would
love that to be more normal in in
Washington
DC you can tell I'm a little too steeped
in libertarian culture because I was I
went to um Bethy Mandel and Carol
martz's book party maybe like last year
and I had my son was I think you know
four months mons old or something five
months old at the time and it was in
Manhattan sort of like in this you know
bar Hotel bar and I was sort of
deliberating oh should I should I bring
my child with me or should I just you
know leave him home with my husband and
how silly of me to assume that Bethany
who has a bunch of kids wasn't also
bring a kid right like I I show up to
her own book party and her her baby's
like in a sweet little sling and I'm
like oh wait a second I'm with
conservatives I'm pretty sure I could
have just brought my kid and it would
have been no big deal whatsoever uh but
there is something so about especially
as a younger woman going into
professional environments when you see
other people who are more established in
their careers and more established uh in
you know building their families there
is something that's very eye-opening
about like oh Bethany is doing that okay
I'll just do that next time perfect and
this is I I say this specifically about
the workplace that um a lot of people
and trying to become a lot of employers
try to become more family friendly by
providing uh better daycare more
maternity leave and all all that stuff
is great
but I say that one of the most important
things that an employer can do is tell
you your family is more important than
this job and one of the most important
things someone like me youve read my
titles earlier they're senior in both of
them right I'm not that old but I have
been at the examiner longer than anyone
else I've been at AI for over 10 years
and when I get up and leave and I say
okay I got to go home my kids need me
and so then the trade-offs that women
have to make because women do a
disproportionate amount of the
childbearing the trade-offs that women
have to make the the way to alleviate
the negative impact on their career is
not to say oh we're going to make it so
you don't have to spend more time with
your kids is to say you know what dads
you ought to go off and spend more time
with your kids and that someone like me
right now I'm not a boss but I am a
senior guy and I make it clear my family
is more important than my jobs and that
that again is setting norms and
expectations so this is something that I
I think this has it's a conservative
argument as you're suggesting but it
should have broad uh appeal to the
libertarian audience I believe because
what I'm saying is not all it's not
mostly about government policy it is
mostly about norms and expectations and
and what we do as individuals and
employers freely choosing rather than
mandating anything on anyone well so you
talk in the book and this is I think the
chapter that I am U most skeptical of
and so you're going to need to convince
me on this one but you talk talk about
incentives that employers can offer to
attempt to ease the burden of having a
lot of children doesn't this just create
extraordinary levels of resentment
between the childless and the child
having like why should you know our
colleagues without children be
subsidizing the actions of breeders like
me and
Zach well because we humans are not a
consumption good in other words if if
you said look I think the employer I
think Reon should pay for my tattoos and
then Peter sudman and Stephanie Slade
who don't want or have tattoos to my
knowledge said wait we're not gonna get
tattoos why should the tattooed be
subsidized by us I would say well not as
outlandish of an idea as you think it is
Tim reason has paid for one of Liz's
tattoos for a documentary Zach helped me
with the
scheme um well that's great I hope it
wasn't like a A mises or a ran tattoo or
anything like that oh no that would be
despicable as long as it's artwork I I
can get behind it I suppose but um so
subsidizing everybody's tattoos it kind
of leaves the people who know they're
not going to choose tattoos feeling like
well couldn't we just have paid
everybody a little bit more and then you
can choose to get a tattoo with your
money that argument doesn't apply for
people and this is again there you'll
detect a religious underpinning in this
argument but people are people people
are that for which the sake for the sake
of which we make government policy or
company policy and I am explicit that
the neutrality that we ought to have
towards in government policy or employer
policy do you have a Tesla or not do you
drive or not do you have tattoos or not
I don't think that neutrality is fit
for family and for children I think we
actually ought to take the side of
families because what are we doing we're
taking the sign of people which is the
natural and good choice to make and the
argument would be different if we had a
birth rate of 3.0 or if everybody was
achieving what their desired uh family
size was but seeing so many people fall
short of their desired family size for a
generation now on something so important
and to see that family and work are the
two main competitors for our time I do
think that it's fitting and appropriate
for an employer to come out and say and
again I'm not saying they should have to
but I'm glad when pro- family employers
Too come out and say actually we're
going to support and we're going to
accommodate family in a way that we're
not going to necessarily accommodate
everything else and to be clear when I
was the opinion page editor here my
accommodation of family included telling
the 24 year-old to go home and spend
time with her sick dad while he was in
the hospital it's not just parents who
were accommodating family with but that
is practically going to be uh the
biggest source of family accommodation
is accommodating parents so is that
totally fair and Equitable by some
measures no I think it is ultimately
fair and just to say your family is the
most important
thing you know one of the the major
developments that I've seen just
anecdotally and also there does seem to
be some evidence uh empirically for this
that has increased family formation and
uh people having well specifically
people having more babies there's a
little baby boomlet post Co and some of
that may have been attributed to
attributable to remote the rise of
remote work and just more flexible
working Arrangements that seems to have
given people little
more uh breathing room
to take their GES to soccer practice or
whatever needs to be done and maybe
opened up more possibilities for
considering more having more kids are
there things that can be done you know
in a more neutral way to just further
enable that Trend because to me that
seems like one of the biggest changes in
my working lifetime the fact that people
have more flexible working Arrangements
um seems moreable to having more kids so
I I do definitely think that flexibility
in all Dimensions is uh is really
important to this and in fact uh the
Nobel prizewinning Economist Claudia
golden I she just won the Nobel Prize
recently she has done all the research
on uh gender and pay and work and all of
that and what she realized is that the
gender gap the difference in Pay between
men and women in similar jobs with
similar amount of education is entirely
due to the fact that women demand more
flexibility that in fact that mothers
demand more flexibility so a one of my
answers is hey men you should demand
more flexibility too B is the more that
you can make your place of work if
you're the the boss be more flexible the
better it is for family and again this
also benefits the guy who's a golf
addict and he wants to be golfing all
the time if he has flexibility um so
definitely absolutely and that not every
job should have to be 40 plus hour
full-time or just a 1099 so that's a
place where government policy It's You
know guys know that horrible law in
California what is it sb5 that basically
out 85 basically Outlaws contract work
that's absolutely an anti-family uh law
so the more that we can allow people to
scale up and scale down through public
policy and workplaces make it very
explicit I think of Journalism but I
think of a a woman I worked with who
when she got married she's like I
basically want to have a baby right away
and so we switched her to editing
outside contributor pieces because that
was perfectly made for working for home
while the the sort of day-to-day writing
and interacting with other writers and
bosses and making phone calls and
checking sources that that didn't lend
itself to working from home with a baby
and so we tried to cultivate jobs for
halftime stay atome moms or dads that's
really something that can be done
neutral towards what you're splitting
your time with it could be splitting
your time with your parents splitting
your time with hiking splitting your
time because eh I've paid off my
mortgage I'm 50 I don't really want to
work full-time but I do want to do some
work that all of that there are some
policies that need to be changed to make
that more feasible and employers
adopting that would be both
familyfriendly as well as ultimately
neutral towards what you're spending
your other time it almost seems like the
Divide between uh the the two I guess
the progressive family Pro-Am side and
the conservative pro- family side is
like the progressive vision is kind of
like uh we need to have all these um
like unlimited Universal daycare um but
also we're not going to allow the this
these kind of flexible job arrangements
so you're going to be working full-time
and your kids's going to be totally
covered in daycare and your side of the
equation is like well if you want people
to make uh if you want people to have
the optionality to have more kids let
them have more flexible working
arrangements and just give them straight
up cash because they can use it how they
want to raise their families is that
kind of the yes the battle you're
fighting yeah in the book I definitely I
say a a tax credit that that currently
exists is basically almost an equalizer
with so that I I use example of Five
Guys who live in a I actually was
thinking of five specific guys who lived
in a bachelor pad in the suburbs right
next to another family of five with the
same aggregate income they should have
the same aggregate taxes that's what the
current child tax credit does I would
expand it a tiny bit by uh indexing it
for inflation and rolling in some other
parent specific child tax credit for
such as for daycare and just have it be
straight cash and let people make the
decision because a lot of people would
decide to work a little less and spend a
little bit more time with their kids and
a lot of people would decide to spend it
on daycare and to work a little bit more
and so in that regard I I do call for
more of a policy neutrality while there
are a lot of people who say no our GDP
needs those women in work let's instead
do a nudge to nudge um every both
parents into working 40 hours a week
full-time outside of the home and at the
same time subsidize the daycare industry
I think that's really bad
policymaking to me the thing that's so
sad about um so much of the progressive
push for Universal you know pre and
Universal daycare is that it acts as
though people all have the same values
and it acts as though all families want
to farm their children out to uh
entities you know picked or approved by
the state and at least for me and my
family that is not true uh I would would
much rather spend more time with my kid
and I'm incredibly grateful to have a
workplace that allows me to I start my
day at 5:00 a.m. most people at reason
start their days you know at 9:00 am or
sometimes a little bit later than that
um but I feel lucky because I write the
morning newsletter for Recon and so at 5
am. before anybody else in my house is
awake I get to actually have you know my
little chunk of intense deep focused
work time for the day and that type of
thing I think you know there's something
so frustrating about the universal
approach the universal this Universal
that uh that's so frequently favored by
status um you know of all varieties and
it's like well what would happen if
instead we enabled families to use their
time and money as they see fit in a way
that is in accordance with their values
versus values that are imposed top down
to me it's very profoundly
frustrating no I I think that's that's
exactly right and I get frustrated I
would read the academic studies while
working on family unfriendly and I would
just see the the absolute Prem of half
of these academics was simply how can we
get more parents to be putting in a
combined 80 hours a week outside the
home and very rarely was it considered
that well how can we give parents more
flexibility to have the work life
balance that they would optimally have
though one thing that I do want to focus
on before we move on from this topic
because I know Zach wants to talk about
housing policy uh in a little bit but
don't the child
already subsidize us all so much in that
their property taxes pay for K12 schools
what do you make of of that component of
this where like isn't the better
approach to try to make it so as few of
us are subsidizing the choices of other
people as possible and to attempt to
unwind the terrible place that we've
already gotten to or are you just saying
we really need to scrap neutrality and
we need to be as a society like all in
favor of trying to promote people
the if you look at the the subtitle of
family unfriendly it's how our culture
made raising children harder than it
needs to be so most of the places in
which I'm saying we should have
accommodation and preference for family
over uh that that those are cultural
changes rather than government policy
and again my argument for a child tax
credit that's slightly bigger than it
currently is is a fairness and
neutrality one and but I do think um
there are people who say children are a
public good I don't like that way of
talking um because for a variety of
reasons that I think you guys could all
figure out but I do think that we should
say well you know what actually children
that a public policy should be oriented
not just towards the present but towards
the future and it's hard to talk about
this without getting sounding super
cheesy but like children are the future
I I think I avoid saying that line in
the book because it's too cheesy but
that helping people raise children even
with pretty secular values is a way of
saying okay we're going to help people
attain their desires or get closer to
their desires in very important things
and we're going to help guarantee that
there is a future which is not
guaranteed in a place like South Korea
and so I don't support huge chunks of
cash for parents for a variety of
reasons one I think ultimately you do
run into an unfairness argument I
absolutely believe that choosing a
childless life an unmarried life or
whatever is um is a totally valid Choice
Catholics have always believe that and
not just for priests and nuns but also
for other people I absolutely understand
that a lot of people who want to have
kids don't end up having kids and can
feel like they're getting ripped off if
they're constantly
subsidizing uh families but I do think
the culture should be set up there's
this term that gets used a lot of times
in Progressive identity politics that
something is too blank normative
cisnormative heteronormative
Etc sometimes that's a problem but I
think that the right balance is often to
be normative but tolerant and I think to
be family normative and single or
childree tolerant is the the right
balance that we expect people most
people are going to get married and have
kids some people are going to choose not
to some people are just not going to end
up doing it and so the the sort of
Hardcore pronatalist approaches you see
that they're trying in Hungary or that
some conservatives and a smaller portion
of progressives want I I don't think
that's the right way to go but I also
don't think that the complete hueing to
neutrality is the the right way to go
and if you're going to resent that we
are being pro family that that's what I
hope in in the book to argue against and
I I spent a lot of pages arguing well
actually even if you don't want to have
kids you should want other people to be
having the families that they desire and
right now we're airing in the S side of
people are not getting the families that
they say they
desire what role does technology play in
all this I mean to go back to the
idiocracy uh moment for for a second
where you've got the yepy couple who
just Waits too long and then they
biologically cannot have a kid anymore
um obviously we've got IVF it to the
extent that that improves life if
lifespans continue
to get longer and uh even thinking way
out there you hear about artificial
wombs and stuff like that will that play
potentially play a role If part of the
issue is people delaying to the point
where they're not able to have the
family size that they had dreamed of
when they were
younger well certainly right now a large
portion of the the shortfall of women
getting fewer kids than they want
happens because of a combination of a
delay and then sort of bad luck and
biological clocks in other words if you
choose to start your family in your 30s
you're increasing the risk that you
won't be able to have as many you're not
guaranteeing it's not even above 50% but
you're increasing the risk that you
won't get the two or three kids that you
want but ultimately the reason I'm
skeptical of some technological fixes to
this is because I think that the the
planning mindset is a sort of uh fatal
conceit the idea that oh with enough
technology with enough planning we can
build the life that we want free of
these other problems I think that really
is a a huis it's an over
um it's an overestimation of our own
ability to plan what we want and to know
what we want I kind of celebrate at the
end of the book The unplanned of
children and life with children every
child is unplanned is one of the quotes
I have in there because even if you
wanted to have a child you didn't get to
choose this specific child I tell the
story of when my oldest daughter was
born and we had picked her name we had
done her Nursery we were totally ready
for her we we knew we wanted to get
married and have a honeymoon baby this
was we had basically I was hoping it was
going to be a girl first we had
basically plan this child she's born and
I look at her I think who is this I've
never met this girl before how am I
supposed to like make her my roommate
for the next 18 years when she's a total
stranger and sure enough like every
child is unplanned and that Serendipity
that it introduces into life is good so
that's one reason that I don't fall into
sort of thinking Tech and planning can
solve all our problems because I think
the the human mind is such
that when we try to plan too much we end
up messing stuff up you know speaking of
planning and fatal conceits I want to uh
going to wrap this up with the a little
discussion about urban planning and
housing and the role that this plays um
I I mean we've seen again post pandemic
there's been an acceleration of
accelerated
migration um from some of the big
Coastal are
to Sun Belt cities I was part of that um
and there's a real question about you
know are I mean one thing is like are
people flocking to the Utah of the world
where um you know is is that how some of
this gets resolved is kind of flocking
to more familyfriendly areas you have a
chapter in the book which is just one of
the greater greatest uh chapter titles
I've ever seen want fun in the sheets
give us walk ability in the streets
maybe just start there what what do you
mean by
that so one of the key needs of parents
is the ability to ignore their children
and not feel bad about it and so Gen X
we used to what our parents told us was
okay make sure when the street lights
come on that's when you come home so
ride your bike walk go wherever you want
that's harder where I moved out of
during the pandemic Montgomery County
the streets were three four lanes in
each Direction it was not walk there
weren't sidewalks in a lot of places and
so if our kids needed to get somewhere
they needed to be driven small local
high schools are replaced by Regional
massive high schools uh which get uh
economies of scale but means nobody gets
to walk to school the walking that
children do do is way down my brother
lives in Connecticut he can almost hear
the crowd cheer at his daughter's little
league softball field because it's less
than a mile away there is no way she
could walk there because there's no
sidewalks and the only Street has people
going 50 miles an hour each way so urban
planning is a place where very
explicitly this is where the government
needs to be pro- family and it has been
family unfriendly to this dat they they
don't build sidewalks I think the the
and the speed limits are too high and a
lot of conservatives and some
Libertarians are kind of instinctively
proar in a lot of ways that I think is a
big mistake it needs to be easy for kids
to sort of run the neighborhood then you
need less um less planning of their
activities less driving less time in
what I call Carell with the buckling and
the unbuckling and the rebuck that you
guys both know very well and then
obviously there's I don't have to deal
with this to the degree that you guys do
deliberate choice because I'm a car haer
right like I mean I am very sympathetic
to the idea that Robert Moses is to
blame for like people failing to have
unpredicted sex right like that is
something that I am definitely
interested because for me at least the
idea of attempting to get children in
and out of car seats and especially like
your car size then limits the amount of
car seat uh bound children you can have
so it necessarily has all of these
Family Planning implications it's a car
seat reception was that that was the
study that I cited that because a car
seat mandates rolled out at different
times multiple Studies have shown that
people are much more likely to stop at
two kids um just to wrap it up as long
as we're talking about policy though
allowing
it's it's really complicated because um
allowing more density does allow for
sort of more playgrounds and makes
housing more affordable and that sort of
stuff but big apartment buildings are do
not turn out to be familyfriendly
because they don't turn out to be
Community friendly right this is one of
the things that surprises a lot of
people because in college you might have
lived in something that felt kind of
like a big apartment building and
everybody knew each other but in adult
life uh the average American apartment
building is not proc communal and
because you need Community to raise kids
those don't end up working as we were
talking earlier you need a mix of lots
of different things you need Garden
Apartments that surround a courtyard
with a playground you need single family
homes but not with minimum lot sizes
that drive up the price of houses and
make it impossible for someone to start
a family and so it would be a lot of
sort of a deregulation B promotion of a
uh a mixture of different types of
housing and then the stuff that the city
that the government has to do which is
pave the sidewalks and pave the bike
trails and build the playgrounds that is
really a a huge part of this and again I
I don't support neutrality I support how
do we build this so as to make this a
place that young people will move and
want to start families but I've I've got
to just point out this sort of uh
empirical reality of where people have
been moving I'm going to pull up one of
those uh pie charts that urbanists who
talk about walkability kind of hate
which is this is from the urban reform
Institute showing that you know uh 50%
of people live in a low density Suburban
environment another 42% in a higher
density Suburban environment America
just has been getting more suburban and
the kind of revealed preference is for
the cars the detached single family
homes and so forth so how do you cope
with or you know deal with that reality
while also making neighbor trying to you
know push for neighborhoods to become
more
familyfriendly there's what I call kid
walkability versus hipster walkability
one of my friends joke that so many
urbanists they what they're really
saying is I need to be able to walk to a
great cocktail bar which is fine I used
to be able to walk to a great
neighborhood Pub and I loved it but kid
walkability and bikeability might mean
you're driving to work you're driving um
your your kid to their Boy Scout meeting
or their Girl Scout meeting or whatever
but the playgrounds and the schools and
the 7-Eleven where they're going to buy
Slurpees and taquitos that they get to
those on themselves so a a suburb can be
sort of pro commuter Pro single family
home while also having kid walkability
at the same
time Tim I want to close us out but
before I do I want you
to give us your 30 second Pitch for why
Libertarians skeptical of your argument
should come over to the Light Side uh
and and be on board yeah yeah give us
your 30 second Pitch because I feel like
I'm a little bit of a fence sitter on
this issue I feel very torn between uh
my Catholic purce and my libertarian
ones and then my actual personal
experience of like I really really value
spending time with my kid I really
really hope to have a large family at
some point give us your 30 second sort
of closing argument for why people
should come over to your side uh with
Libertarians in
mind so first of all a lot of what I'm
arguing for is a a kind of neutrality
and fairness and it's about changing the
culture rather than government policies
to inflict this uh top down but I think
a more childless Society will make
people more staus and make people more
depressed about the future and make
people more fearful I think that when
people have kids they're more hopeful
for the future they're more trusting of
their neighbors a more trusting communal
Society is a place where people rely on
Norms and neighborhoods and uh Goodwill
and they're less likely to think that
the only source of their goods and their
needs is going to be the state so more
babies equals more
freedom fair enough thank you so much
for talking to reason Tim Carney thank
you
you thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and Facebook
page every Thursday and the just asking
questions podcast feed every Friday
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
and please rate and review the
show